So here's the solution
So we want to add an "if" statement because we want to make a decision
We want a test
If the start_link is equal to -1
So that means that we did not find what we were looking for
find returns to -1, so the value of start link is -1
Well, then we don't want to do the rest, we don't have an URL to look for
What we want to do is return the special value "None" and zero
So that's the change
Now when we run this with this string that does not have a link
what we get as the output for the url is "None"
We can't tell that's not a string, the way it prints out, but it's different from a string
and one thing that we can do with "None" is sort of like "False"
So if the value of the test expression in an "if" is "None"
that's treated the same way as "False"
So if url returned here is "None", then we'll print "Not here!"
I guess that means we are here, but we are not "Here!"
So here's what we get, we see that we got "Not here!"
when we passed in a string that did not contain a link tag
if we go back to the string that has a link tag
and now we run the code, we'll see that the url was some string that's treated as "True"
and we get the print "Here!"
So the test condition for a boolean doesn't necessarily have to be just "True" or "False"
Python will interpret different values as "True" and "False"
and the important thing here is that any string value other than empty string is treated as "True"
and we'll go through this part of the "if"
The value "None" is treated as "False" and we will go to the else